[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we bring in mike tarico
he joins us on loan from nbc he'll be
calling that clemson notre dame game
mike good morning how are you what is
your favorite color
in the peacocks the the nbc peacock do
you have a favorite color
well you got lavender on don't you i do
i do my favorite happens to be the
orange obviously the whole syracuse deal
but
just just maybe something to ponder as
you as you spend your time saying
peacock i like the way you say peacock
in the promos
i it's got a punch to it i'm more of a
green guy for some reason
i am infatuated with the color green
really is that right
green jacket mastered master starts a
week from tomorrow so
you're in the mood in the mood good to
see you how you doing i'm good i'm good
but there is a study there's
studies that have been done on the color
that you like
and what it says about you your
personality really yes it's interesting
i i didn't like the color orange until i
went to syracuse now i have like orange
everything
you you name it so i'm curious to see
what the study says that means about me
but you're a michigan guy though you
live in ann arbor i just live here i
i don't i don't uh i i don't root for
the wolverines
you don't no no no no no
you're a one school person and my school
is syracuse i'm an alum there and my
kids go
for them either syracuse no of course i
do when i'm not doing i do their games
once every blue moon i'll do their
last game against notre dame i won't
root for them during the game you can
separate
church and state i mean we've i've been
doing this for 30 years so i i
will root for them in every sport
whenever they're played our friend scott
van pelt has a great line
i borrow it way too often everyone's
from somewhere that's where i'm from i
think there's a 30-year track record
that says i'm fair if i'm
talking about syracuse but when i'm not
on the air you bet i'm rooting for him
i brought this up to rich eisen who is a
michigan guy
and uh but he's not a resident of ann
arbor
and i said you know what would hurt more
losing to michigan state
or losing to ohio state and he said
losing to ohio state and i said no
that's not the right answer
because ohio state is just a neighbor
michigan state
you have to deal with michigan state
every day the guy down the street who
went to east lansing
and you're not expected to lose at home
to michigan state you're expected to
lose to ohio state
wrong yeah i i think if you asked the
people who live
near where i live who have been true
blue michigan fans for years
a michigan state loss disappoints them
in football and ohio state laws
devastates them ruins their year the the
up north uh school up north all that
stuff don't put the m in michigan
whenever michigan does and even uh
urban meyer's wife doesn't put the m and
her last name in her twitter handle
you know it's just that's that's just
the way people are about it
they truly truly are i'll forget dan i i
had uh
i forget what event i was doing i had to
go somewhere where i could drive
so i went to the michigan ohio state
game in person on saturday before i went
to
wherever i had to go to for sunday night
football and i drove
from michigan south through ohio with
michigan plates i got into ohio people
were flipping me off i'm like dude
go orange see that go go go cues i got
nothing to do with this
it really is visceral so the loss to
michigan state really did hurt michigan
fans because they thought
okay building something good year
michigan state looked so bad in week one
new coach and that was just like a punch
to the gut for them knowing
what probably is inevitable down the
line in mid-december when they play the
buckeyes
what is in what is inevitable with uh
his contract
do you think jim harbaugh is there next
season
i do i do dan i i'm going to make a
blanket statement then maybe i'll dive
into the specifics
i think there's going to be very little
movement in college football
college athletics colleges in general
colleges and universities
the budgets are devastated they are
crushed by what by
everything related to covet 19. so let's
start there pay and buyouts is going to
be a problem unless you have one person
who wants to write the check which often
happens but i also think schools are
going to have a really tough time from a
moral standpoint we don't say that often
in college athletics
but this whole year is so so different i
think we
as fans as broadcasters
we're getting into football just like we
normally do what's wrong with belichick
why aren't they doing this
they're we're not putting enough of an
asterisk on this season this season is
so odd it's such a unicorn
i'd really pump the brakes on making big
changes after this year because
it's really hard to judge what anybody's
doing given the build up and the
execution of the year we're talking to
mike tarico football night in america
and
the voice of notre dame football with
clemson coming to town
on saturday night on nbc assess
notre dame at the beginning of the year
to where they are now
in facing this clemson team with a
backup quarterback
it was like the super bowl this was one
big pre-game show leading up to the big
game
the entire notre dame season was lead up
to clemson
that's your measuring stick and brian
kelly came off a four and eight season
four years ago and has had three
double-digit win seasons
now five years ago three double-digit
win seasons and now they start 6-0
they are better i've seen them every
year and seeing nfl
teams on a regular basis you can tell
talent even though
i by no means an italian evaluator
they're better
they've got better players they've got
depth they've got talent
the two games against georgia the last
two years tell me
notre dame can play on the field with
elite talent they're getting really good
players
clemson's the ultimate measuring stick
in the sport along with alabama
this is a chance for them to see
themselves against that
what's happened during the year they're
not throwing it as well as i thought as
i think they thought they would their
defense is probably a little bit better
than they thought they would have
if they can play a possession ability to
run the ball
uh score in the 20s type of game they'll
have a good opportunity to beat clemson
with
dj uyangalalay the quarterback replacing
trevor lawrence
how long did it take you to get dj's
name
oh it came right to me although i must
say
i have been practicing at home like last
night we're watching election results
it's like 1 30. do you want to have
another glass of wine yeah
it's good with chuck and savannah and
lester they're going to go until 3 a.m
we'll hang with them here and uh do you
want another glass of wine and i said
yeah sure
it's become like aloha for everything in
the house right now
hey uh would you like to pick up your
shirts at the cleaner school yeah yeah
i got to do it i think they should just
come up with dj
and then you like like dj you
people calling him dj you his he's
number five he's a big guy
he looks like a demarcus russell cam
newton physical stature kind of guy he's
super talented too
for a true freshman he played great
against diversity against bc
his nickname is big cinco he's got a
chain that says big cinco
i love that nickname i'm like dude i
hope you're good to make it to the nfl
because that nickname will last forever
so not calling or calling games without
fans
you know the college game the college
game stand have been
different than the nfl games they did
the one nfl game in new orleans they
were just family and friends like 500
folks
uh when the game's going on you're
hearing the
piped in audio you can get into the game
not in the same way you would when it's
a big crowd
the college games with 10 12 000 people
and the band
feels not all that bad so the college
games haven't been as difficult
i'm just thankful that we've been able
to do the games in person in south bend
i mean i can't imagine calling the games
off tv i did for the hockey playoffs and
it was a challenge it's so hard to feel
like you're doing the job the right way
not
seeing the field or picking up stuff
that's not just on that camera in front
of you but
it it's been okay look work is for all
of us
any of us who are lucky enough to be
still working right now work is twice as
hard and half as fun
but we're still you know maybe 10 times
more thankful that we're getting a
chance to do it because a lot of people
aren't
in this really tough time isn't it
strange that the
the pac-12 starts this weekend like it's
all
it's such an afterthought we can
normally name
how many marquee guys out of the pac-12
it just feels like
they're just going to put their head
down plow forward get some revenue here
and then come up for air at the end of
the season because nobody's going to
qualify
you know for the final four yeah i think
the big ten in the pac-12 felt like they
had to jump in
because once the acc big 12 and sec got
started
and the college football playoff was
going to happen the college football
players a lot of money
these universities and the athletic
department side need that money
need every dollar they can get so if
they didn't jump in they weren't going
to get some of that cash so i felt like
they'd jump in here
at this point it is odd i feel odd for
the i look at the rankings
and i see ohio state two and oh and
there they are they're two-and-oh and
clemson's like seven no
there's argan in the rankings oh and oh
like what are we doing here
this whole season is the biggest example
of
how ridiculously screwed up college
football is
at that level they need some some common
sense some guard rails to
make everybody play the same kind of
sport what what they've done as the
sport continues to
get more fractured and fractured is is
insanity really is
and i think wisconsin i got an update
here from a source
i think wisconsin is in some serious
trouble i think the entire season
could be they may have to forfeit this
season and you know do they come back
and play those two or three games
because the other teams on this
when their covet outbreak is better
because those teams need the game so
they can play six games
in case there's another you know folks
folks in the other leagues have been
going the whole time had told me
when they were going to start back in
late august early september we don't
know if we're going to play all 10 or 11
games that we're scheduled for we hope
to but we're not sure and the nfl's
still in the same boat you know
i think it's amazing we've gotten to
november uh full credit dan to
the docks the the infection control
officers the nfl teams have
the players too everybody's sacrificing
so
we turn on our tvs on saturday and
sunday it's cool for us it's cool to
work but
people are sacrificing not going out not
hanging out not doing the things in
their normal lives
so they're not the person to infect
their team and i i just uh
tip my cap and say thank you to the
athletes who are making that sacrifice
along the way as well yeah i just worry
uh i remember when the season started
and uh had somebody tell me
wait until schools are out of any kind
of
championship run wait till the players
in the nfl are out of a playoff picture
that's when you have to start worrying
weeks 12 13
14. that's what you know this big
concern
of you know we could have another
outbreak in the nfl
well i'll flip that to the college side
for a second most of the schools have
moved their
calendars up i know my two kids who are
in college will be coming home from
their fall semester where they're
wherever they're doing it
here in the next couple of weeks the
back end of the football season
might be easier for the teams to control
any outbreaks because they're going to
be less people on campus to interact
with
which has been part of the source of
some of the outbreaks for schools so
that that's the
other side of it but you're right you're
one in ten is it is it that same feeling
i think there's a respect for
opponents and teammates uh and the
desire not to be the guy
or the people who because of your
negligence brings down
an entire organization safe travels
there mike
uh always great to talk to you you too
mr man
glad to be teammates again i hope i hope
the election stuff gets counted because
i
i think we might do the clemson game on
saturday it's third and five incomplete
before fourth down
here's chuck todd with an update on
milwaukee county you know i mean
it could be a strange week it could
happen mike it could happen
looking forward to a great weekend thank
you buddy
mike tarico the big event weekend across
nbc sports headlined by brady
brady brady and breeze sunday night
football
number one clemson number four notre
dame saturday in prime time on
nbc